you
I wish we were doing this back in 1984
when I was 24 years old and just
beginning my career because back then I
knew everything
somehow since then I seem to have
forgotten it all and I I do really see
this as a very selfish way to help me
preserve what's left or the very least
jog my memory so that I can maybe
remember why I once loved writing movies
so much
the movies from early 60s into the
mid-70s were the movies that changed my
life
Dog Day Afternoon made me want to write
scripts hand down it was probably a
combination of Harold and Maude and Dog
Day Afternoon that was two movies nobody
won I felt the audience involved in a
way that I just never seen they were so
into the movie they were so so involved
with the characters in the movie they
weren't just watching it they weren't
they were really they were really
invested in everybody
he moves take his head off put the gun
why I'm not gonna make it Sonny
they were emotionally involved I don't
even know how to describe it I just felt
better Mac I was I was you know 13 or 14
when I saw those movies and completely
changed everything for me
Betty Mac I'm sorry Sonny [ __ ] to me
this is the perfect opening scene to a
perfect movie written during the 13 year
time span when most or all of my
favorite movies were written 1962 to
about 1975 most important of all this
was the movie that made me want to write
movies I was 14 years old the year it
came out it was r-rated which meant that
I had to have my mom buy me a ticket and
then I had to sneak into the theater to
watch it most importantly for our
purposes this is one of the ballsiest
scripts ever written it's a movie that
starts out as a movie about a couple of
hapless bank robbers and evolves into a
movie that a that becomes about among
other things how love drives us all
insane there is no score no music at all
beyond the Elton John song over the
opening credits it's all about the words
and in five minutes you fall in love
with these words and with everyone you
see the beginning of a movie
automatically excites me I don't watch a
movie for the first time if I've missed
the opening
and unless you're at a Hollywood
premiere the opening scene is the only
part of the movie you watch full of
nothing but good faith I have no idea
how to write them they take me forever
and I can't I can't move forward until
I've written my opening scene I spend
more time on the opening than any scene
in the script by far I'll take notes
I'll do research do anything other than
actually start writing because I need to
know exactly what it is I'm going to be
fading in on I can't begin until I know
that what is that first line of dialogue
is it over black I do I do that a lot I
have someone say something and then fade
in I don't know why I just started doing
that it's a way to trick myself that
I've done something good call that side
again the radio said it's gonna get down
to 34
it's 34 that's freezing for Christ's
sakes
no chilly what your spacing they're
closing down my grandpa
let theater down on the scanner guy
always one more couple jeez no I was
thinking maybe Momo should buy it I
could run it for him show some old
Cagney movie is a what's moment gonna
want with some broken-down theater shows
movies no one wants to see anymore
outside of maybe turning into some kind
of porno house not gonna get much of a
good talk to this chili besides you have
got a job yeah
hey ray how you doing yeah good you okay
hey you believe this weather and the
beach for Christ's sakes chili Palmer
let's chilly outside and it's chilly
inside it's a regular chili fest all
right and well obviously much better you
chilly
was a good one yeah
first time i adapted a novel it was on
on get shorty i learned very quickly
that if you take a book you love and
just try and put it through the movie
machine just try and turn it into a
movie
becomes a very trivialized version of
the book you end up with something that
doesn't work either as a book or as a
movie it's just sort of its own silly
thing because you haven't made choices
you haven't made hard choices and the
only way I can make choices is to really
write it for myself what is it about for
me sometimes it's something formatic you
know you you you latch on to this
thematic idea and then you call
everything that doesn't speak to it when
you're adapting there are all sorts of
ways but the real trick is is really
making it mean something to yourself as
opposed to simply refashioning it as a
movie are you sure it was Ray bones who
took the coat
who the man said hey tomorrow I see on
the TV whether it's gonna be nice and
warm you don't need the cold this is it
a chilly get the cold just don't piss
the guy off okay
and we're gonna have to call Momo and
straighten the whole thing out the
MoMA's gonna be pissed off for wasting
his time we don't need that
don't worry us any more than I have to
if that
once upon a time back when I knew
everything I would have generously
called myself a writers writer but now
in reality I know that I'm really just a
very lucky guy who having to accept a
lot of writing jobs and this is
something we should probably talk about
why we write what we write how is it
that frequently the things we think are
going to be meaningful that are going to
win awards and become significant in the
cinematic pantheon turn out so shitty
meanwhile the things we do just because
they were handy or we simply needed the
money turn out to be the thing that
changes our lives I wrote out of sight
because I had three kids living in the
same bedroom and I needed a bigger house
and that was the job that was dangled in
front of me I had no aspiration beyond
the desire to have my own bathroom I
never thought about that when I was
young I never thought about how do you
have a family and how do you have a
career and how do you keep them both and
that's a challenge so I think that was a
big part of it and a lot of jobs I took
were jobs because I had my family and
this was a job that I could get and I
thought you know what I'm going to do
this and some of those turned out to be
great experiences but your
decision-making matrix just starts to
change as you go along out of sight
remains for me my favorite and the
single most satisfying experience I've
had in 28 years of writing screenplays I
was even nominated for an Oscar I say
this not to ham handedly drop in the
fact that I was nominated for an Oscar
after all you've had several actual
winners up here before no I mentioned
only because why you do something
doesn't necessarily matter how you do it
is everything maybe the only thing at
least I tell myself that I'm Gary
I'm Celeste it takes forever to get a
drink around here there's only my
mattress no don't go blue guys Bobby oh
they're fine I mean you just got here
you help yourself
you like bourbon I love it we got that
out of the way tell me so last word he
do for a living I'm a sales rep and I
came here to call in a customer but they
gave me a hard time cuz I'm a girl
is that how you think yourself as a
sales once a girl you don't have a
problem with it I like your hair
like your outfit but actually this is my
second favorite outfit I had a first
favorite but it got ruined and I had to
get rid of it you did it smelled really
having it clean didn't help no that's
all me Gary what do you do further or do
you want to go with it not yet don't say
anything yet I don't think it works for
somebody else Gary so last when they
know about naming steven soderbergh
always had a vision for what that scene
would look like and I wrote the scene
instead of it being fractured that way I
wrote the scene where it was happening
on the way it sort of starts in the bar
and then you have these series of scenes
as they go down the hall get on the
elevator walk to the room I did a
different something different and Steven
said to me always would say to me don't
worry I know what I'm gonna do with that
I have an idea I know exactly what I'm
going to do with that and and he made it
sort of a mini model of the whole movie
because the whole movie is is fractured
that way Street and you look at each
other in for a few seconds is kind of a
recognition you both know something the
next moment the person is gone and and
it's too late to do anything about it
and then after that the movie plays
straight out after that sequence there
are no more flashbacks no more anything
the movie just unfolds and so that was
all that was all Steven Soderbergh and
and Coates and in the script it's it's
very straight ahead and I don't think
that interesting also I have to add the
music there David Holmes score is is
amazing so everything kind of comes
comes together and
and much different than I saw it much
much different than I saw it and when I
saw the dailies from the love scene I
thought this isn't going to work this is
so tame this I don't think there's
nothing here and then when I saw it cut
together it was it was amazing to me
more than any other form of writing
screenwriting for better or for worse is
collaborative invariably
the second draft will be worse than the
first draft be ready for it don't panic
but it will reek as the saying goes you
try to please everyone you please no one
what happens is I do this draft I listen
to the person or that person I rewrite
for an actor who doesn't commit I
rewrite for a budget that's made up i
rewrite based on the notes that the
studio head scribbled while reading my
script in the midst of 11 or 12 others I
have my own problems with the script
that I'm trying to fix the producer gets
a last minute thought I try that I try
everything I put it all in there and
it's awful and then strange thing
happens to me every single time and has
for 28 years rather than get depressed I
always without fail get angry at myself
for being so weak and pathetic for not
having the conversation when we were you
know having the conversation and then I
started a new file and I call it my
draft and everybody's ideas everybody's
thoughts everybody else's things they
want me to try all get pushed aside they
all become like the radio in the next
room I can hear them I'm aware of them
but they're not distracting me I wish I
could skip the second draft altogether I
wish there was some way to magically go
from a first draft to a third draft I
wish I could better defend my work in
the room and I wish I could be smarter
you should ask my family what I'm like
when I'm writing a script or when it's
not going well
you're just not present because you're
solving this puzzle there's this Rubik's
Cube you're doing in your brain that
you're constantly trying to figure out
so it's very hard to be present and my
kids dad dad dad they're always doing
that to me what I'm driving dad did you
hear what I just said and and so you're
you're you're focused because because
not having not solved these problems
it's it's maddening and you can't let go
of it and by the same token when things
are going well you're the greatest
in the world and you're having a good
time and so it's it's a moody existence
and so it is it is tough and it is it is
tough on everybody around you or can be
my father was a pilot and liked to take
me flying in his Cessna and so it was
one day at 16 years old when my father
had a heart attack and I found myself at
the controls of the plane moments away
from crashing into the Santa Cruz
Mountains it was then that I first began
to think about writing okay that's not
actually true that never happened but
we're all paying attention to my
artfully described digression my father
was though in fact a pilot and he would
take me flying in his Cessna and once we
would reach altitude he would always ask
me the same thing Scott if I had a heart
attack right now and you had to land
right now where would you land this is I
suppose a perfectly reasonable thing to
ask a 13 year old when you're teaching
them how to fly but with a sensitive
soul like me it can be somewhat
traumatizing and lead to a life where
one is always looking for a safe place
to land and in fact my career has been
defined by what I can only describe as a
consistent failure of nerve fear every
day of every month I wrestle with it but
unlike some writers who bravely channel
their fear into very personal original
pieces I tend to back away so like
sterling silicon I wake up and all of a
sudden I'm a cautionary tale
I'm certainly grateful for any success
and I can point to one or two pieces I'm
very proud of and I'm appreciative of
how much I've learned on the journey as
it were because in our everyday life
learning is the process and the process
as I've said is everything for me what I
really remember and I remember very
clearly is the process on every movie
and and I've had some great ones that
for me is the take away because standing
in the back of the theater watching the
movie it's a it's very hard to get your
head around the how you feel it's like
it's kind of fun when you think about it
really from the outside that you're
standing in the back of a theater and
they're watching your film but it
doesn't doesn't give me anything what I
look back on the process and sitting
with certain directors in particular in
certain producers that's great though
I've always known that I was on the
right train I worried sometimes that I
was on the wrong track
and I thought a lot about this for a
long time and then I turned 50 and all
of a sudden I realized that life isn't
necessarily supposed to give you
everything I thought I would start
directing sooner I thought I thought I
would write more original screenplays
than I have and I didn't realize I would
spend as much time rewriting other
people's screenplays as I have no matter
what I'd done or what I was doing I'd be
wishing I'd done it differently or had
done more and that's a bad place to be
particularly when nothing is especially
wrong with my life
50 is the perfect age I decided to stop
being so afraid I've had a really nice
28 years you know I'm right I've worked
with very good people and I've for the
most part I've had very few what one
would describe as bad experiences or
frustrating experiences I've had a
pretty good time out of sight was one of
maybe the single most satisfying
creative experience I ever have get
shorty was a great experience for me
working on Minority Report was was one
of the greatest most difficult
experiences I've ever had I loved it
Minority Report was a very difficult
screenplay to write because it was
loaded with so much technical detail but
still I said to myself I wanted to read
like a good story and that has to be
that has to be the challenge because
that's how you how you sell it that's
how you get people involved with it and
actors want to be in it
the short story is conceptually the same
thing but ultimately we ended up writing
a brand new movie the first thing that
Steven said to me is write this like
it's happening today if somebody answers
a phone they answer a phone don't
describe the phone if they get in a car
they get in a car for the moment let's
just think about the story which was a
huge relief to me and made it much
easier to think about things and the
movie we watched before I started
writing was the French Connection so we
were really thinking about it as
kind of gritty police movie let's very
briefly just talk about the state of
riding in the Hall in Hollywood just
what's happening now to writers
particularly young writers let me
explain how it works some lower level
development exec who works for the
producer right out of Wesleyan gives the
writer notes and sends him off again
with the notes and the writer dutifully
executes these notes and then the young
development execs suggests a couple more
things based on how one of their other
scripts was received recently at the
studio and the writer makes these
changes and then the development exec
finally hands the script into the
producer who hasn't been in a single
story meeting since they sold the idea
to the studio but as in lots of meetings
at the producers guild where he's on the
board and they're busy trying to limit
the number of producing credits on
movies to only those who actually
produce anyway I digress the producer
reads the script and asks what is this
this is a whole other movie we can't
turn this into the studio and the
development exec goes back to the writer
and says the producer hated it and
wanted to be more like what we pitched
and the writer says but I followed the
outline and made all of your changes and
the development exec says yeah I know
but he wants a new script and the writer
asks timidly his voice barely above a
whisper if he can possibly be paid for
the delivery of the work he's done and
the development exact explains that in
order for that to happen they'd have to
turn the script in to the studio and the
studio doesn't want to do that now and
up his chances because the first
impression is everything everything
everything the writer says but I'm broke
and I need the money so can I take
another job and the development exec
says no way we've been waiting nine
weeks for this as is and the writer says
then I have to turn it into the studio
so I can get paid and so now the
producer who's not bothered to talk to
the writer or been in any meetings up to
this point calls the writers agent and
says your clients being difficult if he
keeps this up he's not going to work in
this hemisphere ever again certainly not
for me and the agent it was very young
and also a bit of a [ __ ] and just wants
to keep it all flowing ask the writer
candy just do a quick draft of what they
want because if he doesn't no one will
work with him and so the writer does the
best he can not really sure what he's
doing because he's well and truly on his
own but he does the best he can because
his wife is going to have a baby and he
doesn't want to be perceived as
difficult so he turns in this new draft
which the producer after two more drafts
when the writer finally signs off
and they turn it into the mid-level
studio exact assigned to the project who
reads it and says she likes a lot of it
but it's not really what they agreed to
and can they have a meeting to go over
it
so they bring the writer in for a
meeting with the mid-level studio exec a
junior studio exec with a pad the
producer the development exactly works
for the producer and anyone else who
happens to be in the building and they
go over the script and they tell the
writer that they can't turn the script
into the head of the studio because
they'll know he'll hate it as written
but if the writer makes a few small
changes but key changes they think it
has a good shot and the writer who's
stunned calls his agent from the parking
lot and says can t get paid for delivery
now and the agent says you got to do
this if you want your movie made and if
you get your movie made you're going to
be worth a lot more than what you're
owed right now so consider this an
investment in yourself and so the writer
dutifully executes all the notes and
turns the script in yet again and the
studio exec hands it upstairs to the
head of the studio without reading it
because the lower-level studio exec
redit and assured her that all was fine
thus covering the mid-level studio execs
ass and the head of the studio only
reads scripts on Sunday between 11 a.m.
and 3 p.m.
reads it and says he loves the idea for
the movie but hates the script and who's
available to replace the writer I think
that's all we need to say about that
what I have to tell myself with those
jobs with rewriting jobs in particular
is because the muscles are the same is
adaptation or writing original you're
just fixing a story you're telling a
story but the approach for me the way to
stay interested is I tell myself this is
going to be an exercise I've never
written a kind of movie like this this
is the challenge I'm going to write a
horror movie I'm going to rewrite a
superhero movie or a war movie or what
have you
and I'm going to I'm going to figure out
how to bring to bear all the things I
say belong and good storytelling no
matter what the concept it is and see if
that's possible to do 99% of the time
what you get sent you're actually
surprised they're making it you're
actually surprised that somebody wants
to make it nobody has no buddies there's
no love in there nobody's loved this
thing nobody's there they've been sort
of thrown together there apart and again
we're talking about assignments not
original scripts for the most part not
something that somebody created on their
own and worked on and and because those
movies usually get written by one person
there usually there's usually only one
name associated with really original
material but the stuff that sort of
developed you you see that people have
just sort of come and gone and nobody's
really taking care of anything or really
thought about it and I recognize how
arrogant that sounds but it's it's um
it's interesting and why they're making
it often has nothing to do with the
values we would all we all care about in
the story
I've talked a lot and enough I think so
I'm not quite sure how to stop so I
think what I'm going to do is I'm just
going to show you the very last and very
short scene from out of sight it is it's
my favorite scene in the movie and for a
couple of reasons
I've been stuck on how to end the script
for months and in a moment of
desperation I called up the novelist
Elmore Leonard and asked him if he had
any ideas
I just couldn't end the movie the way
his novel did where the federal marshal
shoots the bank robber she's just slept
with and then heads back home to Florida
Elmore told me he liked the way the book
ended just fine but that he'd think
about it but right now he said he had to
hang up the phone because he was about
to talk to a guy from Texas who broken
out of prison over a dozen times I said
wait what who and so we talked a little
more and I wrote this scene we busted
out I prefer to think of it as an exodus
from an undesirable place how long
before they caught ugly that time yo
Elish yeah that was the ninth the ninth
well ten if you count that prison
hospital in Ohio I walked away from and
when I walk in here he the Jireh Jireh
now we're off to glades yeah it looks
that way I was supposed to leave last
night with the lady Marshall but for
some reason she wanted to wait she did
huh
guess his cheaper taking two of us down
in one van could be
maybe she thought we had a lot to talk
about really like what I don't know
long ride to Florida
you
you
you